since when are Moscow and Cairo ever
basically the same temperature like
one's a desert city near the equator and
the other is King Moscow also exposition
by news broadcast is the new reading
meanwhile in Moscow where it's a balmy
Cairo like 24 degrees Celsius
oh cool Bruce Willis is in this does
this look like a man who's about to go
on vacation again how did johns cop
buddy get this information about the
arrest and even know it was john's kid
without somebody from the government
telling them and then wouldn't they also
tell them hey they're working undercover
so don't go over to moscow and blow that
buy get involved this is a stupidest
piece of paper ever so john wrote down
his son's name with question marks is he
unsure of his son's name and he has the
arrest report but he doesn't know what
precinct his son is at or which district
he was arrested in or what the charges
are oh it's murder
better draw a box around that so i make
sure to remember also he draws hearts
and happy jack-o'-lanterns oh and look
at this cliche coffee stain that
couldn't be more perfectly fake i don't
forget money garden ring is bad always
traffic always traffic got it
always traffic at the garden ring I
can't imagine that'll come into play
though so you could have just said it
once alright alright this Russian dude
is a terrible Argyle substitute when
John gets out of the car his cab is in
the far left lane and there aren't any
trees over here on the right but then in
the next shot is cab it's magically in
the center lane and there are trees all
around on that right side where the
other nine lanes of traffic go also this
just gets out of his car and leaves it
unattended and so does that woman this
will definitely not help the situation
people well they can't be all that
worried about security if they're going
to March these important criminals right
through the angry mob this vehicle is
much too large and heavy to have the
kind of pep and acceleration needs to
actually be involved in this chase scene
the spin move by McClane is just
flat-out moronic but then this is the
icing on the cake of stupid why'd you
say McClane thinks the angry motorist
should know he doesn't speak Russian
just by looking at it random zoom shot
to make the car chase more exciting
everything about this bridge changes
before MacLean decides to crash down
below the bridge in this shot has metal
guardrails suddenly McClane looks to his
right in the barrier is glass with steel
frames and there's a whole street that
wasn't there before
back to the old rails here now the
bridge looks like it has an entirely new
barrier and a place where pedestrians
can walk now McClane breaks through the
glass barrier which is apparently is
only obstacle to getting down to the
street below also the glass breaks twice
terribly convenient traffic jam complete
with giant truck for easy landing
McClane drives into a truck full of
gravel and over
cars without stalling or ever getting
stuck then he kills more motorists by
smashing all the cars in sight this SUV
apparently can smash into an armored
truck and significantly alter its path
father and son staredown made possible
through slow motion why is the objects
in mirror are closer than they appear
warning in English think seriously this
man which was pushed for hundreds of
feet with its tyres burning and smoking
the whole way can now drive as though
nothing happened this is what the Bible
had in mind when David beat Goliath only
the Bible story is way more believable
this truck is being driven by no one all
the bad guys survived the crash that was
certain death John playing oh hey it's
that guy I'm on vacation wait no you're
not you came to find out why your son
was in Russian Jail
you nearly cried about it see you that
guy know you're not on vacation damn it
I wonder if they have a five ruble
footlong this hotel is very serious
about its security except when it comes
to entering through the back of the
hotel Girl From Ipanema elevator
musically shame I guess we have found
that before what given a random Russian
laundry worker American money and
somehow communicated to him that what I
wanted in return was the hotel master
key which he somehow has as a laundry
worker all with money I should have even
had in the first place since I gave my
cash to my son several minutes ago after
he smashed my phone yeah I've done that
a few times
I took Gotti lien wow so that totally
random thing the cab driver said twice
to John about garden ring having traffic
actually came back into play the
director said eat a carrot during the
scene so people will know you're an
asshole annoying chewing of the carrot
can be heard throughout the entire scene
but the carrot never gets any shorter
the bad guy swallows the bite of carrot
he never even took in the first place
and then more chewing could be heard
even though he hasn't taken another bite
still chewing so the two bad guy guards
behind them can't see the knife but
McClane can see it out the tiniest
sliver of peripheral vision killing bad
guys that's our thing your thing is also
killing tons of innocent people as long
as you kill the bad guy - Jack
immediately knows that John is gonna
start shooting the convenient glass
ceiling without discussing it beforehand
why does the bad guy wait this whole
time to start using the helicopter to
fire into the room or jack
Jack and John somehow know there's
something to break their fall on the
outside of this window okay so now the
tube was broken but Jack and John fall
the rest of the way down without
breaking any bones or dying
cops everywhere but no one wants to ask
Jack and John any questions after they
need the bleeding it just got shot up
siphoned weapons-grade uranium got
greedy caused the meltdown Jose what we
know we were always told it was a power
surge and the emergency shutdown that
caused the disaster
John steals these keys from where again
and why does this one set of keys open
three different trunks gelée see he
forgot to make this with his toes
compared to seven four
if you try this radiation trust me oh
okay then you say so random evil
daughter no I guess they're at the
swimming pool portion of Chernobyl the
one with competitive diving platforms
John Waring stable in this pool oh I
already trusted you completely after
that whole compound 24/7 if everyone in
the room knew the camera was a surprise
bad guy why didn't they just go ahead
and shoot this Carradine douchebag
earlier so Komarov has to hope he
survives this courthouse bombing
chagarin's Henschel obviously he hopes
that his daughter will rescue him at the
courthouse but doesn't count on Jack
whisking him away now he has to find a
way into the heavily guarded hotel to
find the ballroom that is under
construction
he hid this key for five years while he
was in prison and somehow no one has
stumbled upon it during the
Reconstruction and hopefully no one runs
across a secret stash of uranium that
just happens to be stored in a secret
room of the Chernobyl nuclear power
plant what exactly have these bad guys
here for discount the rock don't worry
the flames that are engulfing the entire
room can't hurt you as long as you're
behind a filing cabinet nice vacation
now a specific trip or journey usually
for the purpose of recreation or tourism
movie thinks it's just like the original
die hard this would definitely kill him
several times over ah so that's why they
had to be in it and everyone believed
the two Americans story about how all
those Russian nationals died in a fiery
explosion and the radiation turned out
to be no problem for either of them
go to Chernobyl
Here I am stuck in the middle with you
yes I'm stuck in the middle with you